denial was like the the main spiritual
path that people took to understand who
they are from the very first human being
that walked along the Nile understanding
itself in every one of our cells we have
denial path within because every human
the first humans in the world in order
to expand through the world had to go
through the Nile so where did humans
first come from women started in Africa
of course we have been updated from
Africa they started to expand and they
started to be modified in Middle East in
Siberia uh in the Americas we have been
in Encounters in constant constant
encounters with other species from other
places
that had download information into us
but the main species that created the
humans
the first cells were in Africa